let's jump into some phone calls here
and see who wants to talk to us today 6
1 7 8 3 0 47 50 is the number rule we
will start with our caller from the two
1/4 area code caller from 2 1 4 go ahead
hi David it's Frank look write again
from Dallas Texas what's going on Frank
okay so I got a question about the
question a little bit discussion about
is this new tax plan that seems to have
passed yeah about to be signed by so am
i right this all just trickle-down
economics again I'm sorry you said what
was the question is this all just
trickle-down economics again all over
again yeah that's the principle of it
that's the principle of it which is that
the economy will do well by virtue of
giving corporations and rich people tax
cuts now they're also they're sort of
claiming that it's demand side by saying
that it's a middle-class tax cut but as
we know more than 50% of Americans over
the long term are actually going to see
a tax increase so the underlying
principles that would make a Republican
support this are basically the same
trickle-down voodoo economics type
things that we know are completely
debunked and have never worked yeah it's
never worked
I mean we're I mean this was tried like
in the in the late 1800s even and it
didn't work so what's what's interesting
to me is that from what it looks like
it's the people that make what 75,000
and under are really going to be
penalized around 2021 isn't it seems
like that was most of Trump's base the
people that hired him the people that
wanted his so-called change right seems
like those were the people that were
kind of having a tough time you know
with you know jobs and and he actually
says I think he just recently said that
jobs are going to be pouring into the
country because of this tax plan right
that can't be valid right people won't
be pouring in because of the travel ban
but the jobs are going to be pouring in
yeah it's none of its bet it's valid and
even though you know earlier this week I
interviewed Scott Adams the creator of
Dilbert and he says that it's not
bamboozling it's just leadership that we
don't like no Trump is bamboozling and I
push back on that because he promised
one thing and he's doing another he
promised a populist governance
and instead it's totally oligarchical
and and you're absolutely right but and
you know what I just I hope that his
voters will punish him for it but I
don't know that they will yeah yeah they
seem pretty hard-headed yeah
well it takes a lot David all right
Frank appreciate it very much always
good to hear from Frank make right